Çeviri: Nadya Alasad
Gözden geçirme: berat güven
Hepimizin bir sürü sıkıntısı,
derdi var, öyle değil mi?
Dört dörtlük bir insan modeli yok.
Olmasın da zaten.
Çünkü bence insan en çok
yaralarından tanıyor
kardeşini, yarenini, benzerini, sevdiğini.
O yüzden ben hep dinleyicimle
bir yara kardeşliği kuralım istedim.
Böyle korkmadan, sakınmadan,
müzik aracılığıyla, şarkılar aracılığıyla
birbirimize yaralarımızı
gösterelim istedim.
Fakat son dönemlerde böyle
pek hoşuma gitmeyen bir söylem var.
Diyorlar ki "Aman işte
sıkıntılı insanların yanında durmayın,
aman üzüntülü insanların
yanında durmayın,
sizin enerjinizi düşürürler,
kendilerine benzetirler, uzak durun."
Ben de böyle söyleyen insanlara
şunu sormak istiyorum:
Bizden ne istiyorsunuz? Ne yapalım?
Mutlu insanlar ırkı mı kurulsun?
Üzüntülü, sıkıntılı insanlar
bir yere mi kapatılsın?
Dünyada yeterince ırkçılık yokmuş gibi,
birde bu mu çıksın?
O yüzden, ben istiyorum ki
bugün inadına yaralarımızdan bahsedelim
ve yara alma endişemizden bahsedelim.
Bize diyorlar ki "Aşkınızdan
fazla bahsetmeyin.
İşte sevginizi çok belli etmeyin
çünkü nazar değer, göze gelirsiniz."
O noktada da bende böyle bir takım
endişeler oluşmaya başlıyor.
Diyorum ki; ya gerçekten de
Türk filmlerindeki gibi,
hani böyle her şey güzel giderken
birdenbire kötü bir şey olur mu?
Yani o malum atasözündeki gibi;
çok gülersek ağlar mıyız?
İşte benim hiç sevmediğim bir söz daha.
Neden çok güldük diye ağlayacağız?
Neden bir bedel ödemek zorundayız?
Sanki böyle tepemizde biri var,
parmağını sallıyor, diyor ki
"Aaa, sen çok mutlu oldun,
Bir dakika, bu kadar mutlu olma
ben seni biraz ağlatacağım.
Ya, böyle olmaz".
Sanki cezalandırmak için bekliyor bizi.
İşte aslında bu bizim
genlerimize kodlanmış
çünkü dünyanın hiçbir yerinde
böyle bir atasözü, benzeri yok.
Bizim kültürümüzde var.
Ve işte aslında
evhamın kaynağı da bu biraz.
Hani dış dünyanın
tehlikeli bir yer olduğu,
biraz korkutucu olduğu, her an başımıza
kötü bir şey gelebileceği inancı.
Fark ettiyseniz benim de
bu konudan bahsettiğimi görüp
biraz böyle kaygılı,
endişeli bir yapım var aslında,
çok neşeli görünmeme rağmen.
Diyeceksiniz, nasıl başladı bu iş?
Hani psikiyatrlar hep der ya
"Çocukluğunuza dönelim,
çocukluğunuza inelim" diye.
Valla çocukluğuma inmeye bırakın,
anne karnına ineceğiz,
çünkü benim o dönem başlıyor.
Şimdi benim annem de biraz evhamlı,
kaygılı bir insan,
biraz değil, hatta fazlasıyla öyle.
Ve benden önce 5 tane çocuğunu düşürmüş,
dolayısıyla korkuyor.
"Aman kızım, düşme!"
"Aman kızım, sıkı tutun!"
"Aman kızım, bizi bırakma!"
Hep bunları söylüyor bana hamileyken.
Ve bir şekilde artık doktorlar da,
uzmanlar da kabul ediyorlar ki
bebekler anne karnında,
annenin sıkıntısını,
depresyonunu, korkularını
hissetmeye başlıyor,
o enerjiyi öğrenmeye başlıyorlar, diye.
E' ben de öğreniyorum tabii.
Üstelik bir de erken doğumum,
yedi buçuk ayda fırlıyorum, birdenbire.
Bu sefer de "Ay, çocuk erken doğdu,
başına bir şey gelir mi?
Aman komplikasyon olur mu?
Hastalıklara yakalanır mı?"
endişesi devam ediyor ailede.
Bunları da tabii ki sürekli
görüyorum, duyuyorum.
Çocukken, bu arada en sevdiğim şey,
hiç umuyorsunuz biliyorum ama
şarkı söylemek. Aynen şimdi olduğu gibi,
en sevdiğim şey şarkı söylemek.
Ve 8 yaşında,
TRT Ankara Radyosu Çocuk Korosu
sınavlarını kazanıyorum.
Yalnız, bir otuz özel ses
arasına giriyorum böyle.
Şimdi, o otuz özel ses
8 yaşında olmasına rağmen
özel olduklarının çok fazla farkındalar.
İnanılmaz kibirli bir ortam var.
"Benim sesim şöyle,
benim kulağım absolute."
Herkes birbiriyle rekabet içinde.
Ama 8 yaşındayız, şu kadarız ha!
İnanılmaz bir rekabet var.
Ben valla ne sesimin özel olmasıyla,
ne işte kulağımın absolute'luğu ile falan
hiç uğraşacak halim yok,
benim başka bir derdim var.
Bende inanılmaz yoğun bir şekilde
bronşit ve astım var.
İşte annemin korkuları
biraz gerçekleşiyor,
o bir takım komplikasyonlar
gerçekten de oluyor.
Fakat bir mucize de oluyor;
müzik beni iyileştiriyor, şifalandırıyor.
Yani tıp ilaçlarının da mutlaka
etkisi olmuştur, hani...
şey yapmayayım şimdi,
haklarını yemeyeyim
ama müzik beni iyileştirdi.
Ben öyle düşünmeye tercih ediyorum,
hiçbir şey kalmıyor bende.
Korodan mezun olduğumda,
15 yaşında, ne astım ne bronşit,
bomba gibiyim.
Ama tabii ki fiziksel olarak iyileşsem de
o sürekli maruz kaldığım evham, korku,
hastalık düşünceleri bir yerlerde
pusu kurmuş bekliyor,
sonrasında ortaya çıkmak için.
Eh, çıkacak tabii yavaş yavaş
ama 15-16 yaşlarından sonra
işte bir o ergenliğin de verdiği
bir özgüven var ya,
böyle işte cesaretiniz geliyor,
evham falan hissetmiyorsunuz
ben bir böyle iyice güçleniyorum.
Üniversiteyi burslu kazanıyorum. Yetmiyor,
her sene bölüm birincisi oluyorum.
Yetmiyor, üniversite genelinde
birinci oluyorum.
Şimdi o döneme baktığım zaman
şunu düşünüyorum;
neden böyle devamlı
birincilik, birincilik?
Muhtemelen kaygılarımı, anksiyetemi
bir şekilde, hani çok güçlü olursam,
çok mükemmel olursam,
o şekilde bastırabilirim düşüncesi,
belki altında yatan.
Sonrasında, Amerika'ya burs kazanıyorum,
İstanbul'da yüksek lisansı kazanıyorum.
Hani, şimdi diyeceksiniz
"Haydi özgüvenin tavan olmuştur."
Vallahi öyle olmuyor!
Amerika bursum, yüksek lisansım
karşımda duruyorlar
ve ben şunu fark ediyorum;
benim ne Amerika'ya
ne İstanbul'a tek başıma
gidebilecek cesaretim var.
Maalesef kendi başıma
bunu yapabileceğime inanmıyorum.
Nasıl yaparım? Nasıl kalırım?
Nasıl tek başıma baş ederim
bütün bunlarla?
Ve işte o noktada anlıyorum ki
ister üniversite birincisi ol,
ister dünya birincisi ol,
ister dünya kraliçesi ol,
eğer kendi başına kalmakla,
kendinle başbaşa olmakla ilgili
bazı sıkıntıların varsa çözemediğin,
o zaman, o birinciliklerin
çok da bir anlamı olmuyor aslında.
Üstelik ben o dönem, bu korkumla
yüzleşmek zorunda da kalmıyorum,
çünkü sağ olsunlar annem, babam,
beni çok sevdikleri
ve çok düşkün oldukları için hemen
benimle beraber İstanbul'a geliyorlar.
Ben tabii oho, yüksek lisansı rahat rahat
bitiriyorum ailemle kalarak,
iletişim uzmanı oluyorum,
üstünde bir de
edebiyat mezunu olduğum için
ilk romanım çıkıyor,
böyle genç yazarlar arasında
takdir görüyorum,
iyice egom şişiyor "Ha ha" falan,
çok mutluyum.
Zannediyorum ki
ne korku kalmıştır, ne bir şey.
Yok, yine öyle değil.
Tam o dönemlerde, annem ile babam
tatile gidiyorlar.
Ben de evde yalnızım.
Ve diyorum ki akşam Taksim'de
arkadaşlarımla buluşacağım.
Annemi arıyorum, haber veriyorum
"Anne, ben akşam Taksim'e gideceğim."
Annem her zaman ki o evhamlı haliyle
diyor ki "Aman kızım, sakın gitme!
Taksim çok tehlikeli yer,
orada başına bir şey gelir.
Bak, biz de yokuz... biz de yokuz,
sen...işte...bir şey olursa...
nasıl...koşacağız?"
Çok sinirleniyorum, "Anne" diyorum,
"Ben 23 yaşındayım.
Hâlâ bana diyorum
"Anlatmaya çalışıyorsun,
evhamlarından bahsediyorsun,
hiçbir şey olmaz.
Ben kendi başımın çaresine bakarım"
diyorum, telefonu kapatıyorum,
gayet cesur bir şekilde
Taksim'e gidiyorum,
bir saat sonra panik atak geçiriyorum.
Şimdi, panik ataktan çok bahsetmeyeceğim
çünkü geçirenler bilir,
geçirmeyenleri de gereksiz yere
paniğe sevketmeye gerek yok.
Ama panik atağın kendisinden
daha kötü bir his var
o da; ya bir daha geçirirsem endişesi.
Buna işte, beklenti anksiyetesi deniliyor
ve ben bunu yaşadım.
Hayatımda bir kere panik geçirdim
ama ya bir daha geçirirsem endişesini
defalarca yaşadım.
Hâlâ ara ara yaşıyorum.
Hani baş etmeyi öğrendiğimi düşünüyorum,
eskisine göre çok daha iyi durumdayım
ama o mücadele aslında hâlâ devam ediyor.
Arada böyle kafasına uzatıyor
"Ben buradayım.
Kork istersen benden" şeklinde böyle
arada kafasına uzatmaya devam ediyor.
Tabii o dönem ben...ay, işte
panik atak geçirdim,
eyvah deyip, boynumu eğip
hayatıma o şekilde devam etmedim.
Ne yaptım? İşte araştırmaya başladım,
psikiyatrlara gittim,
yazılar okumaya başladım
ve şunu sordum kendime;
ben neden başıma kötü bir şey
geleceğini hissediyorum?
Neden öyle düşünüyorum?
İşte orada bir şey fark ettim.
Uzmanlar diyorlar ki;
bizler başımıza kötü bir şey
geleceğini düşünüyoruz,
çünkü olay olduğu anda bu şekilde
hazırlıklı olacağımızı sanıyoruz.
Yani kötüyü prova ederek
o olay olduğu anda
daha kolay atlatabileceğiz durumu
gibi hissediyoruz.
Ama bu külliyen yalan.
Çünkü panik atak geçireceğim
korkusu yaşayan biri, örnek veriyorum,
bunu sık sık düşünen biri,
panik atak geçirdiğinde
hiç düşünmeyen birine oranla
daha kolay atlatmıyor olayı.
Aksine, sürekli düşündüğü için,
bu duyguyu kendine sürekli yaşattığı için,
olayı olduğu anda, korku geldiği anda,
daha yorgun, daha bitikin,
daha dayanıksız hale gelmiş oluyor.
Yani hiç de öyle düşündüğümüz gibi değil.
Panik atağın kendisi zaten 35,
maksimum 40 dakika sürecek bir şey
ama genelikle 15-20 dakika
arası devam ediyor.
Sonrasında vücut zaten ister istemez,
yani mecburen normale dönmek zorunda
çünkü adrenalin deşarjı...
devamı olamaz, yani fiziken mümkün değil.
Ama, ya geçirirsem korkusu,
o işte bütün bir ömre yayılabiliyor.
Yani üstelik topu topu geçireceğimiz
panik atak belki bir kere
dediğim gibi, yani ben de hayatımda
bir kere yaşadım.
Belki iki, haydi üç ama
ya geçirirsem korkusu,
işte o defalarca yaşamak gibi bir şey.
Şimdi, yapılan iki araştırmadan
bahsetmek istiyorum size.
Başlarına kötü bir şey geleceğinden
korkan insanlara sormuşlar,
10 sene sonra.
Demişler ki "Başınıza o korktuğunuz
kötü şey geldi mi?"
Çok büyük bir kısmı demiş ki "Gelmedi."
Diğer bir kısımda demiş ki
"Geldi ama sandığımız kadar kötü olmadı."
Yani belki hiçbir zaman
başımıza gelmeyecek
ya da gelse bile sandığımız kadar
kötü olmayacak bir şey için
bütün hayatımıza harcayabiliyoruz
ve o noktada sınırlamalar başlıyor,
kendimizi sınırlandırıyoruz.
Ne yapıyoruz? Belki uçağa binmiyoruz,
belki evde yalnız kalmaktan korkuyoruz,
yolculuğa çıkmıyoruz, bir sürü konuda
kendimizi sınırlandırıyoruz.
Ve şunu sormak istiyorum:
İşte bütün bu ödediğimiz bedel
ve bunca önlemin bizi ödettiği bedel,
gerçekten bütün bu bedele değer mi?
Gerçekten bunca önlemin
bize ödettiği bedel ne?
İkinci bir soru:
Bu kadar büyük bir bedel ödememize
sırf belki kötü bir şey olur diye
gerek var mı?
Bu bedeli ödemek
asıl kötü olan şey değil mi?
Elimizdeki tek hayatı hayali şeylere
önlem alarak harcamak ne kadar doğru?
Sırf o duygu gelmesin diye çile çekmek,
o duygunun kendisinden
daha sıkıntı verici değil mi?
Size şahsen deneyimlemiş
biri olarak söylüyorum.
Yemin ederim! Daha sıkıntı verici.
En kötü olasılığı düşünmek,
bana kendimi önlem alıyormuşum gibi
hissettirse de, beni hayata karşı
daha kırılgan yapmıyor mu?
Çevremle ilişkimi bozmuyor mu?
Gerçekten bu soruları sorduğumuz zaman,
cevaplarını siz de biliyorsunuz,
ben de biliyorum aslında.
Ve bir şekilde o kaygılı hâl hafifliyor.
Çünkü aslında son derece
makul düşünen bir tarafımız da var,
bütün o panik anımıza rağmen.
Yapılan bir diğer araştırmadan daha
bahsedeceğim.
Stresli insanlara sormuşlar,
bunların bazıları stresin sağlıklarına
çok zarar vereceğini düşünüyor,
bazıları ise stresin sağlıklarına
o kadar zarar vermeyeceğini düşünüyor
ama hepsi stresli.
Bu stresli insanlardan, bir kısmı
sonrasında gerçekten
korktukları rahatsızlıklara, hastalıklara
kapılmaya başlamışlar.
Diğer kısmı daha az kapılmış.
Yani, stresin kendisinden çok
stresin sağlıklarına zarar vereceği
endişesi ve korkusu onları hasta etmiş.
İşte bu noktada, anlamlar,
bizim yüklediğimiz anlamlar çok önemli.
Anksiyeteye yüklediğimız anlam,
korkularımıza yüklediğimız anlamlar,
bizim bu korkuları hayatımızın
neresine koyduğumuz,
çok ama çok önemli.
O dönem gittiğim psikiyatrım
bana demişti ki
"Aydilge, anksiyeteyi öcü gibi görüyorsun,
ona öcü anlamı, canavar anlamı veriyorsun.
Yani onu yaramaz, haylaz bir çocuk
olarak da düşünebilirsin" demişti.
Şimdi, hani okulda zorbalar vardır böyle,
iş yerinde de vardır gerçi.
Hani böyle bizimle dalga geçerler,
üstümüze gelirler, ağlatmaya çalışırlar.
Eğer biz onlara cevap verirsek,
gerçekten ağlarsak, üzülürsek,
kaçarsak, bastırmaya çalışırsak,
atar geçersek, ne olur?
Biraz daha uğraşırlar, daha hoşlarına gider
çünkü görmek istedikleri şey ilgidir.
İşte anksiyete, sıkıntı, korku da böyle,
ilgi gördükçe kalmaya devam ediyor.
Ama eğer onu hayatımızın merkezine
koymaktan vazgeçersek,
onu normalleştirmeye çalışırsak
ve ona bir büyüteçle bakmaktan vazgeçersek
aslında büyüteci kaldırdığımıza,
kendi boyutunun o kadar devasa
olmadığını görüyoruz.
Ama büyüteci biz tutuyoruz ona
ve o canavarlaşıyor.
İşte yüklediğimiz anlam
o yüzden çok önemli.
Uçak, uçağı ele alalım.
Kimisi için çok korkutucu bir şey,
kimisi için ulaşımını
kolaylaştıran bir araç.
E' uçak aynı uçak!
Ama yüklediğimiz anlam farklı.
Bizler farklı anlamlar yüklüyoruz.
İşte bu noktada, dediğim gibi
aslında işin çözümü:
Biz korkumuzla ne yapıyoruz,
korkumuzu nasıl değerlendiriyoruz?
Uzmanlar diyorlar ki;
bu konuda kontrol sizde
ve kontrol sizde değil.
Şimdi diyeceksiniz ki; nasıl yani?
Hem bizde hem değil.
Şöyle, olayları önceden
engellemeye çalışarak
kontrol etmeye çalışıyoruz ya!
İşte bizi bu kontrol
hasta ediyor aslında biraz da.
Fakat diyorlar ki; olayları, kötü şeyleri
engelleyemezsiniz,
önceden kontrol edemezsiniz.
Hani bir kısmını kontrol ettiniz diyelim,
hani düşünebildiklerinizi,
öngörebildiklerinizi kontrol ettiniz,
ya ön göremedikleriniz ne olacak?
Dünyada bir sürü felaket olabilir,
ya hangi birine yetişeceksiniz?
Hangi biri için evham duyacaksınız?
Ama kontrol edebileceğiniz
bir şey var diyorlar.
O da, olay olduğu anda,
vereceğiniz tepkiler
ve yüklediğiniz anlamlar.
İşte bu çok önemli,
biz başımıza gelen kötü olayı
nasıl değerlendiriyoruz?
Yani o olay olmasın diye
bir sürü önlem almaya çalışmak yerine
olay olduğu anda,
acaba onunla nasıl baş edebileceğimiz
üzerinde kafa yorsak, daha iyi olmaz mı?
Yani düşeceğim diye korkup da
koşmaktan vazgeçmek yerine,
düştüğümüzde nasıl kalkacağımızı
öğrenmek, nasıl kalkacağımız konusunda
deneyım kazanmak, sanırım daha...
daha mantıklı,
daha işe yarar bir çözüm
diye düşünüyorum.
O dönem psikiyatrım bana
bir şey daha söylemişti, demişti ki
"Aydilge, anksiyeteni sev."
Dedim "Niye seveceğim anksiyetemi?
Nefret ediyorum anksiyeteden,
hiç de güzel bir şey değil.
Ben süper, böyle güçlü
bir insan olmak istiyorum.
Hiçbir sıkıntım, derdim olmasın."
O da demişti ki
"Sev, çünkü seni sanatçı kılan,
seni nazik, ince, diğer insanların
dertleriyle, sıkıntılarıyla
empati kurma yeteneğini sana sağlayan
hep o anksiyete.
Seni gerçekten duyarlı kılan
ve yaratıcı kılan özelliklerinden biri bu.
Tabii ki kötü yanlarını törpüleyebilirsin,
törpülemen gerekiyor
ama onu tamamıyla yok etmen doğru değil,
asla doğru değil" diyordu bana.
Ben o zaman onun ne dediğini
anlamıyordum, hiç anlamıyordum.
Sonrasında, Amerikalı bir psikiyatr olan
Abraham Twerski'nin
bir tane videosunu izledim.
Videoda Abraham Twerski
ıstakozlardan bahsediyor.
Diyor ki "Istakozlar
sert kabukları altında
narin, yumuşak hayvanlardır
ve büyümeye başladıkları zaman
kabukları onlara sıkıştırır."
Şimdi diyor ki Twerski
"Eğer ıstakozlar insan olsalardı
kesinlikle gidip o sıkıntıyı
bastırmaya çalışırlardı.
İşte bir takım, bir şekilde
kendi sıkıntılarını uyuştururlardı.
Aşırı televizyon izlemek,
aşırı alışveriş yapmak
aşırı yemek yemek, sigara içmek,
vesaire vesaire.
Ama ıstakoz öyle yapmıyor,
ıstakoz gidiyor bir kayanın altına,
kabuğunu kırıyor ve daha yenisi,
daha güzeli, daha sağlam bir kabuk
kendi vücuduna uygun olarak gelişiyor.
İşte, ıstakozlar ve insanlar büyüdükçe
kabukları onları sıkıştırır.
Aslında, stresli ve sıkıntılı zamanlar
büyüme zamanımızın geldiğinin
o konfor alanından
çıkma zamanımızın geldiğinin işaretidir.
Bize daha iyisini, daha güzelini,
daha yenisini arattıran
içimizdeki huzursuzluktur aslında,
çünkü olduğumuz yerde
sayarız, öyle değil mi?
Devamlı hayatımızdan memnun,
mesut olursak,
hiç kimse gelişmeye, daha iyisini,
daha yenisini arama ihtiyacı duymaz.
İşte o yüzden:
Sıkıntılı, stresli, zorlu zamanları
birer canavar olarak,
kötücül birer şey olarak düşünmektense
onları, bizi daha iyi
bir versiyonumuza dönüştürecek
birer çıkış yolu aracı olarak düşünmeye
ne dersiniz?
Çok teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkış)